let's bring in our panel early fox news
senior political analyst brit hume
harold ford jr former tennessee
congressman ceo of empowerment inclusion
capital kimberly strassel a member of
the editorial board at the wall street
journal and trey gowdy former
congressman from south carolina britt
you covered colin powell for many years
your thoughts on this day
well he was a giant whose influence
spanned at least three administrations
that of ronald reagan that of george h.w
bush and that of george w bush
my first memories having brett were date
back to 1989 early part of 1990 when the
u.s invaded panama a conflict many will
not even remember
to take down the corrupt
criminal
dictatorship of manuel noriega who had
whose administration down there had
declared war on the united states big
mistake um and powell came to the white
house to brief this was at a time brad
it should be remembered when skepticism
about the utility of american military
force was very much in vogue
and powell's briefings were absolutely
dazzling a convincing authoritative
crisp clear very much like pal the man
himself
and it really served to put to rest i
think the doubts that had begun to begin
to grow and of course he later was an
architect a major architect of the first
gulf war as jennifer described which was
a thunderous
military success uh for which colin
powell i think deserves a great a great
deal of credit he he planned it he
defended it uh he was a big part of it
later he came to controversy as we all
know over the iraq war and his speech at
the u.n
claiming that uh saddam hussein had
weapons of mass destruction it should be
remembered in that regard brett that
while that intelligence proved to be
faulty virtually every intelligence
service on earth had reached the same
conclusion so he was far from alone in
that
a man for his time
and a man i think we will all remember
with with admiration
yeah that uh commencement speech we saw
part of it in 1994
uh from general powell let's take a
little clip of that more of it
america is a family there may be
differences in disputes within the
family but we must not allow the family
to be broken into warring factions
from the diversity of our people let us
draw strength
and not see weakness
believe in america with all your heart
and soul with all of your mind you are
its inheritors and its future is today
placed in your hands
you know he's remembered for breaking
glass ceilings harold but that's
those presidents valued his uh advice uh
ronald reagan all of the presidents brit
just mentioned uh from your perspective
your thoughts today
uh i think brett uh brit said it very
well thanks for having me on he he was
bigger than life
and bigger than life for those who
pursue a life in government in public
policy
uh he wrote a book his last book i think
was it worked for me it was his
leadership lessons on life
and there were 12 or 13 lessons but all
of them stand out but really three stood
out for me he said get mad then get over
it
he said be kind
i said share credit if we could have
more of our leaders exemplify that in
business politics academia media
would be a different world we live in a
different world
now he wasn't partisan but he was
principal he was kind but he was a quiet
and undeniable force for all the
presidents and leaders uh not only
american presidents but foreign leaders
who he gave advice to those who sought
his advice in the process
i was reminded as i said earlier britain
i were on earlier he he he's sort above
the politics colin powell did and that
was one of the reasons why i think there
was some ambiguity around his politics
all the times that he's all the time
that he served the bush family and the
reagan family as president
when in many ways what he was was a
patriot more than anything and i think
the gratitude we owe him for those of us
who love politics those of us who've
been in it and those who seek to seek to
serve
is to remember all of his lessons
and that is first and foremost serve
america serve our people and as he told
those students at howard university
don't just find the fault fix it don't
curse us we're america we're bigger
we're better and if we are at our best
we can solve any problem he will be
missed his family know they should know
they are in our prayers and they should
know he made america a better place
yeah kimberly
yeah you know i've always thought when
you look at colin powell his real legacy
is not so much any of his individual
actions although there are obviously
some very important ones and one that
people forget is the incredibly
important role he played in the wake of
vietnam of rebuilding a military that
had been racked by discord and
demoralization that was very important
but the legacy is really in the example
of his life and his service which is
rooted in that opportunity of america
it's hard to find someone who came from
more modest means he was born of two
immigrants from jamaica grew up in
harlem to reach higher military or
diplomatic heights i mean we have been
going through his list of titles and he
always credited america for that
opportunity and he paid it back so many
times over in terms of his service and
so that to me is just the the example of
his life is is what is people are going
to remember
troy we don't know what he would have
been like as a president he definitely
flirted with it as we talked about in
the piece
his wife really didn't want him to run
but
you know in 1996 he was close
yeah brett i i think the two lessons and
i'll start with this one um even though
i think it's less important how much the
the country and the party have changed
since 1994 since he gave that
commencement address since 1996 you know
the republican party has changed
dramatically and i wonder if the message
he had for the graduates i wonder if it
would even resonate anymore but the real
lesson i took this morning not the
titles that he acquired not even the
positions he held but how he described
himself
husband father grandfather that's how he
wants to be remembered and if that's how
we want to be remembered that's probably
the order in which we should live life i
think that's a lesson for all of us
yeah brit last word
he will be remembered for all these
different positions
but he was kind of a larger than life
figure in washington
yes he was widely admired
uh it was it's been mentioned that you
know he was approached by the republican
party and boomed in the republican party
to run for president but democrats would
have been happy to have him running
their party too such was his reputation
and his standing it was bipartisan the
admiration
it came he came to some
grief with the republican party after a
while
um he was a dissenter basically on the
on the iraq war and so on uh and then
there was a moment that i think he would
prefer to forget and many of us would
and that was during the investigation of
the of the famous valerie plame cia leak
in which it turned out that his top aide
had been the leaker
and pal knowing that sat in a cabinet
meeting with with president bush
president george w bush who said he
wanted to know who it was
karl rove was relentlessly pursued on
that ultimately not indicted and justly
so
but pal knew knew and should have said
and he didn't but i will say this karl
rove is one of the people who spoke most
admiringly about him today which tells
you a lot about carl and tells you a lot
about powell you're quite a man
panel thank you we'll see you later in
the show hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else